[Music]
[Music]
so I think many of us have experienced
this where it's we've created a cool
shiny application and you want to share
it with somebody so here's an example
this is from our China gallery somebody
who created a seed is a data
visualization application for data from
the Center for Disease Control and let's
see if let's say you've created a cool
app like this and you want to share it
with somebody well doing that right now
is is very easy it's always been you
know one of the really easy thing to do
with SHINee you just send somebody a URL
they go to it and they can see your app
but it's if you if you wanted to share
not just the app but you know the work
that you've done in the app like let's
say you've you know I've interacted with
this application and I've selected a
particular disease you know date range
location and so on and I want to share
that with somebody of the particular
state of this application that that
isn't as easy to do so you might find
yourself writing emails like this so key
word back okay
and all this previous outline so this is
the boss subject pertussis data it
allows here's the app that shows the
latest data to see the results go to
this URL for disease name select
pertussis four choose date range make it
start from 2014 for plot type choose
weekly data by year the plot options
check include alert thresholds then you
should see what I'm seeing
enjoy your holidays so you may have you
know you may have if you've worked in
shiny applications to share with people
you may have done this before and I'm
sorry this control panel keeps popping
up okay
so you may have done this before but it
would be nice if you could write an
email that's more like this here's the
latest data just send a URL enjoy your
holidays and and you know and and that
particular application that example that
I showed is just there's only four
settings on there but there still you
have to say you know do this and this
and this and this and for more complex
apps that might be might have an even
longer set of instructions for how to
get to a particular state so in order to
do that to send something not just an
app but also the state of the
application you introduced this feature
called bookmarkable state and this was
released with shiny 0.14 which came out
in September I believe okay so now I'm
gonna illustrate this with a very simple
example I'm going to illustrate how you
use it
okay so I'm gonna start with a very
simple demo app that it should be easy
to follow so this is an application with
just one input and one output and oh
I'll show you it in running live here
okay so we'll run that and I enter text
hello world and it outputs the same text
down here so that's that's the that's
the basic app now if I want to be able
to bookmark the state of this app
there's just a few changes that I have
to make to the code so so this is what
it looks like and this is this is with a
this is for a single file app just an
app dot R so here's here's the few
changes that I need to make first off
the user interface the UI part of it
needs to be a function that returns the
paid that UI components so instead of UI
being fluid page it's a function that
returns this fluid page etc etc and it
takes one argument called request
that argument doesn't actually get used
but the function needs to take that it
doesn't it doesn't get used in this case
but there's other reasons to use it that
aren't related to bookmarking okay the
next thing that we need to add is a
bookmark button somewhere so that the
user has a way to actually tell us that
where they want to bookmark a particular
state and then when you call shiny app
you just need to add this part at the
end enable bookmarking equals URL just
need to add that one argument okay and
so this is the single file app the app
dot our version if you want to do a if
you're writing an app with UI that our
and server are it's very similar to say
UI is a function at a bookmark button
and then you have in your global that
are you say enable bookmarking URL this
time it's a function called enable
bookmarking instead of an argument to a
function well that's that's all you need
to do and I'll show you how that works
of it what that looks like run my code
here all right
so and when I click on bookmark this
dialog box comes down and it gives me
this this bookmark location link so I
can copy this and I'll paste it into a
browser and the application is restored
with the same state that we got over
here all right they both say hello world
and so for implementing bookmarking for
simple applications that's that's really
all you need to do okay oh yeah
how this works in a an application that
supply deployed in our gallery this is
an example application it's again it's
also very simple but I want to show you
what the URL looks like so there's just
a slider here that controls the number
of observations so I'll just move it up
to let's say it's 241 so and then I hit
bookmark this is what comes down this is
this URL and paste it into a new browser
window I get the same results here okay
alright so this is an example of a URL
encoded bookmark and what that means is
that what that looks like is first you
have your you know this is your path to
your application here and then after
that there's this question mark and a
bunch of stuff after it so what this is
saying yeah I won't go into the you know
we don't you don't have to generally
know the details but I'll explain this
shoot briefly is this means these are
the inputs and then there's an input
name 2n with value 1 2 3 and input name
texts with the value of ABC ok so that's
that's what that would be for this
particular example but that's not the
only way that we can do bookmarking so
another way to do it is to use bookmarks
that are saved on the server so if for
these type of bookmarks the instead of
encoding all this information about
these inputs in the URL all of that is
saved on disk
and then and it's given ID an ID and so
when you want to send a URL to somebody
with that state the URL is just includes
this part there's a state ID equals and
then you know whatever that unique that
unique idea is ok so that's all right so
I'll talk about some of those in depth
about some of the differences between
these two types of bookmarking
a bit first I'm going to show you how
the save to server book markings are how
you use it so it's very similar to the
URL encoded bookmarking so the UI just
takes you it's function at a bookmark
button the only the real difference is
you need to have this argument enable
bookmarking set it to server instead of
URL and that's that's it that's only
difference from you know from the
perspective somebody who's reading the
code all right so so here's some of the
differences between these two types of
bookmarking for the URL encoded
bookmarks there's as we said there's no
state saved on the server all of the all
of the state is contained in the URL and
if it's safe the server it's obviously
the status served on the server for URL
encoded bookmarks the URLs can become
long so if you have a lot of you know
like those examples that I showed you
have just have one input or two inputs
but if you have a lot of if you have a
lot of inputs for your application those
or you know if those inputs have very
large values like you know if you've got
a text input with a very long string
that somebody's typed in the URL can
become very long and that can be a
little unwieldy if you're sending it to
somebody and if it's a chess server that
it's always a short URL the state that
state ID is always the same size and
because the urls are long with your own
coded bookmarks you can run into
problems with some browsers some
browsers can only have take URLs that
are up to about 2,000 characters and
lengths and if your URL exceeds that I
believe it'll just get truncated and so
when you try to restore your application
it probably won't restore correctly and
what for if if the state is stated on
the server there's no limit to what how
much data you can store for your uncoded
bookmarks you can't save files that have
been uploaded in that URL but if it's
saved to the server you can and finally
these your URL
go to bookmarks as of now they can well
these can work on any hosting platform
so like shiny server or shiny apps at
i/o or our studio konnekt whereas the
saved server bookmarks work shiny server
only right now okay so I'll go into the
for a little bit more depth here when we
when we talk about deploying the
bookmarkable apps the various hosting
platforms out here's a table filter what
you can do on the various hosting
platforms so when you're just running
these applications locally on your own
machine like like I'm doing right now in
these examples or when you're developing
an application both types of bookmarking
will work if you have tiny server Pro
you can use both types of bookmarking
and same is for true for a shiny server
open source if you're deploying your app
to shiny off stuff I owe you can use the
URL encoded bookmarks but the save to
Server ones are still in development and
the same is true for if you're using our
studio konnekt no URL encoded bookmarks
will just work with the sip server
bookmarks there's still some work that
needs to be done for that to a function
okay so those are some very simple apps
applications and for a certain class of
applications it is it is that easy to
determine bookmarking you notice don't
add it a few lines of code but for more
sophisticated applications you have more
complex behavior there might be some
other things that you need to do so and
that's that's when calling advanced
bookmarking okay so now we're gonna get
into some technical details about these
applications so the applications that I
the simple application that I showed you
before is what I'm calling a fully input
dependent application now this
term is just something I made up but it
may be better we have a better name for
it but um I couldn't think of one
offhand so if you've got suggestions let
me know all right so for this type of
application the state of the outputs at
time T is fully determined by the state
of the inputs at time T so that means
that you know whatever the value of the
input was before if I had typed in
something besides hello world before and
then and then I change it to say hello
world whatever the previous value was
that does not that does not impact the
current state of data that text output
alright for these types of applications
but Martin should just work and to hear
some diagrams if you've read the the
article that we have in our shiny dev
Center about about reactivity these
diagrams may look familiar but you know
here this is a very simple relationship
between an input and an output so we've
got input dollar n and output dollar
text so it's just a render type render
text takes input ends and that's the
value of output dollar text
so whenever input dollar end changes
output dollar text changes and this the
value of this is doesn't depend it it
depends only on the current state of in
together in and you may even have a
chain of these things so here is a input
dollar n is being used by this reactive
called the n1 and then output dollar
text uses and 1/2 to get the content
that it's going to display so so this is
there of a chain with this reactive
value input dollar n reactive expression
and then this output but again this has
a similar relationship where output
dollar tax depends only on the current
state of this input and it could be it
could depend on the state of multiple
inputs as long as it's just the kind of
state of them and not any previous
States
okay now contrast that with what
- partly input dependent application
again if you've got suggestions for
better terminology it's um I'd be happy
to hear that so the state of the outputs
at time T is only partly determined by
the state of the inputs at time feeds so
other things may influence it including
inputs at previous times or perhaps you
know external data sources and these for
these applications that were quite a bit
more code so bookmarking to work all
right
here's an example I won't run through
there I won't walk through the code but
I'll just I'll just run it and you'll be
clear what's going on here
this is what I'm calling an accumulator
oops an accumulator it's just it's just
adding values so I've got the slider
here make this bigger anyway so it's up
to 50 right now and if I click Add it
adds it to the sum and if I set it to
you know a hundred with an excuse me I
don't know I'm not seeing your screen oh
I'm sorry
did it disappear did it just disappear
now yeah just disappeared now okay okay
I don't yeah this sorry Thanks
presenter controls are growing a little
bit wonky okay let me uh I'll try
running this again okay it's so I've got
a son right here and I've got a current
value and if I click Add it'll add that
current value to this song so I've added
50 to it I can say AB 80 to it and then
I can you know let's say add 20 and so
on so this in this application the state
of the sum depends on the value of this
input not just now but also at previous
times one of the previous times when I
click to add alright and if I book
market I'll copy this link I'll paste it
into my browser window look like this
and and as you can see the Sun that is
displaying is 50 which also happens to
be the current value of the slider so
that's this is in this in this case
bookmarking did not fully save and
restore the the state of the application
alright so let's talk about why that is
well I see it seems to be losing the
display when I switch from keynote to
the other programs okay I'll just
remember that alright so this is the
server part of the this is the server
part code for for that application it's
it's not too too complicated these are
the important parts so first this is
this reactive values on that stores some
I've got an observer event which every
time the add button is clicked it adds
the current value of input n to the sum
and then and and then when dolls
some changes that causes us render
trucks to be triggered and it updates
the value that's printed on them the
some value okay and and this is what we
saw before
I like the Sun once it was 200 I clicked
up though and the current slider is on 5
I clicked bookmark and then when we
restored it I ended up with the value 50
here which is not that's not correct
okay so in order to deal with this sort
of problem there's some called X that
there's some functions that you can use
to register callbacks when an
application is bookmarked and when it's
restored so because in for this
particular application we need to save
some extra State that's not just the
current input values the current input
values are saved automatically when you
bookmark when you but this we need to
save some other information as well so
these two callback registration
functions are on bookmark and on restore
so what this one does is we call on
bookmark and we pass it a function that
takes one argument state and and and
what it does is when it executes sus
when you when the user clicks the
bookmark the bookmark button so and it
saves Val's dollar-some into these state
values so this state dollar values is a
it's essentially a list and you can just
put in arbitrary information in there so
state dollar values and dollar currents
um we're just we're just saving the
current sum in there and when we restore
the application instead of starting up
here where the sum is zero with starting
with that value what we end up doing is
we extract the saved currents on out of
the state and put that in Val's
dollar-some okay and this
is well this is part of the this will
get us part way there let me show you
what happens if we run this okay okay
but this is a application with it's the
same code except there's these bookmark
and restore callbacks okay so I'll say I
click add a bunch of times
bookmark it and if you can if you can
see this there's this extra part of URL
called values and current Sun is 200 so
that's that's that the value that I
saved in there with that on bookmark
call that function paste that in my
browser we forget it looks a little
different so here the sum is 200 and
here the sum is 250
so let's possibly a little better and oh
that's not quite right and let's let's
see where that is okay
what's happening is that there's the
after the application is restored input
dollar add has some value like four
that's the number actually that happened
that's the number of times it's an
action button and that's the number of
times the action doesn't has been
clicked and because I so value for it
triggers this observer it triggers this
observer so this the sum before this
observer fired was 200 and then that's
right after application is restored and
then this observer gets triggered and
then the Sun gets goes up to 250 because
it's it thinks that we click the Add
button one extra time so and this is
because of the way that action buttons
work they they have some numeric value
that represents the number of times that
are clicked and for this observe event
if that number if that value is above
zero then it will execute this at this
expression here so one way out of this
it's not the only way out of this but
one way out of this is to not bookmark
bad button so that when the app is
restored that it will start with a value
of zero and won't fire this this
observer event so and this is what we
just saw in order to exclude a value
from being bookmarked there's a function
called set bookmark exclude so we're
just saying set bookmark exclude and the
name of the thing that we want to
exclude is is add and this can be you
know you can you can pass in a vector of
names
we're just excluding one value here so
let's try serving this close that from
this
okay so some of 200 hit bookmark copy
this and a new browser tab the sum now
displays 200 and if you if you were
watching very closely this is the this
is the current URL that I have inputs n
equals 50 and then there's this values
currents one equals 200 and in my
previous attempt I also had there's also
this ad equals four that was being saved
in the state there but my current
attempt that's no longer there and
that's because we excluded them so so
that worked great alright and this is
again what we saw we started with this
the state of the application where the
Sun was 200 we bookmarked it and then
when we restored it restored the correct
value of 200 okay so so for these sorts
of applications where there's this the
the state of the application is a little
bit more complex than you know those
fully input dependent ones that I
described in the beginning there are
these useful callback functions so
there's on bookmark and on bookmarked
this function so the way that these
these pairs of function works are when
somebody clicks the bookmark button just
before shiny actually saves the state of
the application it runs this on bookmark
callback and then afterwards it runs
this on bookmark at callbacks and
there's some there's some reasons that
you'd want to use these two different
functions and one for restoring or
there's the same as the same a similar
pair there's on restore which happens
just before the application is restored
and then on restored and that gets
called just after the application is
your story and in the documentation
there's some there's some examples that
explain when you'd want to use these two
different things and finally if you want
to exclude values from bookmarking
there's the set bookmark exclude
function so I excluded the action button
that add action button but there's a you
know there may be other types of things
that you'd like to exclude okay so you
know going back to our original story
here like say if you've got the school
app and you've said it to a particular
state so now that you've learned
something about bookmarking you probably
could write as an email like this here's
the latest data and just send the URL
and that will send not just the
application but the work that you've
done in the application and if you'd
like to learn more about it
you can visit the shiny dev center there
we have an article section or the
articles page and then there's a section
in there called bookmarking State and
that will that includes some more more
technical details if you'd like to learn
more about it so there it is thank you
very much
okay so here's one of the questions is
can this kind of bookmark can be done
with shiny and our markdown and a pretty
sure the answer is yes so that's been
tested before there was um there's I'm
trying to remember in order for it to
work properly you need to set an option
in our markdown to have it be have it be
pre-rendered I forget the details about
that though now hopefully we can look
that up and somebody can look that up
and give some more details about that
that was actually a new feature that was
implemented in the last couple of months
for our markdown I believe okay can I
bookmark the contents of an uploaded
file if I were to assign the contents to
a variable yes you can do that so I
think this question relates to what I
said about a URL encoded state not being
able to contain a file so if yes if you
were able to take out the contents of
that file and save it save it to a
separate value then you
could that could be part of the bookmark
but you'd have to use you'd have to use
that on bookmark and on restore because
the file so with with file uploads the
file it's content itself is actually not
an input value it behaves a little bit
differently and so that part doesn't
automatically get bookmarked when you
say enable bookmarking what you need to
do is use the on bookmark callback
function extract that file content and
then save it in you know state dollar
values dollar file content and then with
the on restore then you restore it there
okay can bookmark and be done with Flex
dashboard I I'm not 100% sure of this I
believe it can because Flex dashboard is
using our markdown but it does work I
believe it also requires us pre-rendered
as this tiny pre-rendered option to be
set okay in in this safe to server mode
is the user able to download the file
that contains the saved state of the
application in addition to getting the
app URL I believe this is this is
technically possible because the state
does include the directory where all
these files are stored
so each whenever the this estate is
saved to the server it's a new directory
is created and all the all the necessary
information is saved in there and it
should be possible to retrieve that
there's not there's not a simple API
exposed to do that it is possible to
find that directory and then you know
you can zip up to all the files in that
directory if you wanted so it's I guess
it's possible but not I mean it would
it's not trivial for you know for most
users I think
performance implications freezing
bookmarkable state for bookmarking
there's no if you just turn it on for
your application there is no overhead
like performance penalty it's only when
the bookmarking actually occurs that
something that there's any computation
now in many cases if you're just saving
the values of inputs it's a very very
small amount of data so it's happens
very quickly if the one place it can get
large is if you have large uploaded
files it can save the state it'll make a
copy of this these uploaded files and so
that can be that could potentially be
consuming a lot of disk space on the
server is there security value of using
the server versus URL method well with
the URL encoded bookmarks all of the
state is at least the state for all the
inputs is is encoded right there in the
URL so if somebody else is able to get
ahold of that URL they can see they can
see what what inputs one has set now
that itself may or may not mean
depending on your situation it may or
may not be a security issue but if
you're you know if the app also requires
a login to say test Chinese Server pro
or aren't you to connect then you know
that's that's an independent thing so if
the person is all is not able to access
the application then it's possible that
the information in the URL is not it's
not going to be all that useful for them
for server uh for server-side
bookmarking I don't I don't think there
should be any security issues other than
you know the state obviously is saved on
the server so if somebody has access to
the server they can well and they might
need super user access they might then
they can look at different state files
if they have access to per user access
to the server you have security issues
anyway if you have dynamic UI elements
ie one QR element reacting to another is
there any issue with the order in which
the UI elements are restored or are they
all restored at the same time so this
was actually a restoring dynamic UI was
actually one of the challenging that's
in implementing bookmarking for shiny to
make sure that that behaves that page
seamlessly typically I guess it depends
on the specifics of your of your
application we tried to make it so that
for if your application has any dynamic
dynamic UI parts they should just it
should just work even if even if there's
a some of them depend on some other
other dynamic you already inputs that
should just work in most cases I believe
we talked about that in some other
articles on the on the shiny dev center
okay have you experimented with auto
bookmarking or every time the user
doesn't action the state is bookmarked
and you can playback a user set a
session by auto playing every save state
URL you know we actually have not tried
that we there's actually in so in the
again in the in the documentation we
there's an example of an example where
when the user interacts with the
application instead of having them click
on a button for bookmarking it actually
changes the URL in the browser's
location bar and that can be that can be
updated automatically in fact I can
probably just find that okay so this is
an example where when I type in
something like a cdefg the URL updates
as I'm typing so everyone
when we can click this checkbox and as
you can see this URL updates dynamically
so this is this is this isn't exactly
what the this doesn't exactly answer the
question that the person asked but
something similar can be used where it
reacts to every time somebody makes a
change to inputs and you'd have to but
you have to figure out your own way of
saving the information okay how does the
server admin manage Elysee up States so
this is something so right now it's each
of the safe States is just a directory
with you know like that that's sort of
unique ID on it and there's all for each
application there's a directory that
contains sub directories with those
names so right now we don't have like
four shiny server and Chinese server Pro
we don't have like a really easy
administration tool before that
hopefully we will at some point in the
future I mean unfortunately the best I
can say right now is that you could sort
them by by their dates and then do
something with it that way like if you
want to just call like bookmarks that
have that were created a long time ago
or were only accessed within you know or
we're not accessed recently you should
be able to do that but there isn't a
nice front-end tool for that but that's
that's something that hopefully we'll be
able to bring to to our well to the
various lifting platforms okay what
about timeout clean up a safe States I
think this is a similar question that's
a similar question so yeah the answer is
you'd have to use it the best way right
now is to use you know standard UNIX
administration tools so I see one more
here
bookmark and using state IDs can you
examine input parameter values
server-side in some way if I if this
questions asking what I think it's
asking I think when you when the on
bookmark callback is invoked you can
look at the state or when on store
callback is invoked you can look at the
state and if you know if this is
question is asking about examining those
values offline outside of a session the
answer is yes it is possible when the
files are saved on the server so that
state object is is saved as an RDS
object which are can just read in using
read RDS and then you can examine the
contents of it so it is possible to to
look at the contents of those input
values
[Music]